in Hong Kong this morning police fired
tear gas to break up what is the 13th
weekend of pro-democracy demonstrations
protesters were also hit with blue dyed
water when police used a water cannon to
try to push them away from the
barricaded zone authorities say some
protesters responded and threw gasoline
bombs toward police lines the violent
clash is happening near the Chinese
government's main office in the city
Remy innocencio is in Hong Kong
thousands of protesters defied a ban to
March today what they're doing is
illegal but it seems that their anger
against their government Trump's their
fear of getting arrested that anger has
only grown in the past 48 hours
police arrested nine pro-democracy
legislators and leading activists to
take them off the streets and to
intimidate the entire movement that
includes Joshua Wong one of the student
leaders of the 2014 umbrella revolution
he is now out on bail today is also the
5th anniversary of when Beijing rejected
Hong Kong's call for universal suffrage
Hongkongers don't have the right to
directly elect their chief executive
Carrie Lam is now polling at record low
approvals but they can't vote her out
and so they keep taking to the streets
this Sunday marks the start of the
fourth month of protests this weekend
will continue to be unpredictable there
are already calls to block the roads
leading to the airport there are also
calls for students to boycott their
classes which start next week Raymond
Ascencio CBS News Hong Kong